I want to start just by asking what is
what quantifies near-death experience
sure now different researchers have
different concepts but the research
definition that I've always used is
exactly what the name implies you're
near death in other words you're so
physically compromised you're
unconscious or you may be clinically
Dead with absent heartbeat okay now at
that time it should be impossible to
have any Lucid conscious remembrance and
yet people do have that remembrance at
that time and that's the experience part
of a near-death experience what I have
observed and and other near-death
experience researchers see is that very
consistent pattern of what happens when
you have a near-death experience well of
course there's that life-threatening
event they're unconscious or clinically
dead no heartbeat but at that time a
very common first element is what's
called an out-of- Body Experience okay
Consciousness separates from the
physical body and goes above the body
now from that vantage point they can see
ongoing Earthly events often including
people frantically trying to bring them
back to life they may then go into or
through a tunnel variably described
often at the end of the tunnel there's a
beautiful unearthly they emphasize light
in that after passing through the tunnel
then at that time they may be in an
unearthly what some call a Heavenly
realm aptly described it's very
different from what we've known
everywhere on our Earthly life it's
literally a non-physical realm movement
is non-physical communication is
essentially always telepathic uh time is
almost invariably described as either
radically different from Earthly time or
not existing at all in this realm this
unearthly beautiful Heavenly realm there
can be encounters with deceased loved
ones there can be a review of a part or
all of their prior life called a Life
review at this point they can be uh
colors like in plants and and Landscape
that are so beautiful that there are no
earthly words that they have to describe
them there can be buildings around this
time there's often a decision that they
make as they interact with other beings
about whether to stay in this beautiful
unearthly realm a return to the Earthly
life and that body struggling to survive
let me give you an example of what I'm
talking about we had one relatively
recent near-death experience lady was
riding a horse and was out you know
basically breaking in the horse and the
horse threw her off and she hit her head
very severe head injury immediately
unconscious she had that Out of Body
Experience Consciousness above her body
saw her body lying on the ground saw the
horse heading back to home but then her
Consciousness went to where she had
started prior her journey the barn and
she was able to hear other people
talking aware of what they were saying
doing they didn't know that she was
fighting for her life over a mile away
because they weren't aware of that they
only were aware of that when the horse
arrived without her and again she was
able to see and bring back all that
information verified down to the finest
details of what she was seeing and a
mile away obviously there's no way
you're going to see here or perceive in
any way with your normal sensory
function so people leaving their
Physical Realm right you leave you es
and I I guess do they
feel okay being away from themselves do
they feel like Jeepers I got to get back
in myself like when you lost your phone
or something you know or does it feel
like that's what I would be like gosh
cuz if I'm just Ming around it's almost
like you're just naked like you're as
naked as you could be you're naked down
to your soul you know that's a good
assumption and I kind of wondered about
that too early in my research but
amazingly even though these people are
unconscious or clinically dead and may
have had you know severe trauma or
illness problems that led to that
episode of unconsciousness when that
Consciousness separates from their
physical body they essentially never
describe any pain it's unusual for them
to feel fear about Consciousness apart
from their body far more commonly
described is a sense of calm a sense of
Peace a sense amazingly that this is
actually their real conscious self that
being non-physical and apart from their
body down below ah so that's a common
thing that people say oh this felt that
felt a lot more real than the existence
I've been having in my body oh
absolutely in fact we have a survey
question and we ask people you know
about what they said said what they
ultimately decided about the reality of
their experience and in our survey of
834 people that had a near-death
experience where we asked that question
93.8% said their experience was
definitely real and over and over as
part of that they were saying it was
more real than anything they'd known in
their Earthly life they typically have
acceleration of Consciousness uh
amazingly the substantial majority even
though they're physically unconscious or
clinically dead are are actually
thinking processing at a speed they
simply couldn't have done in their
Earthly life okay and why is it at that
time that you shouldn't be able to have
any Lucid like brain activity why is
that sure let's talk about what happens
to the brain after a cardiac arrest
which means the heart stops beating okay
the moment the heart stops beating Theo
obviously blood immediately stops
flowing to the brain 10 to 20 seconds
after that event the EEG which is
electron cogram a measure of brain
electrical activity okay goes absolutely
flat there's no measurable cortical
brain activity 20 seconds after the
heart stop after the heart stop and
after blood stops going to the brain it
should be impossible to have any
remembrance at that time let alone the
highly lucid and organized near-death
experience everything I knew as a
physician told me this is not possible
you can't have highly Lucid conscious
experiences when you're unconscious or
or clinically dead and yet here the very
first few dozens of people sharing with
me very clearly and what was very
impressive is the remarkable consistency
of the elements they were describing
what happened during the experience the
elements or if you will characteristics
okay not only were they very
consistently seen across many many
near-death experiences but they
typically occurred in a very consistent
and logical order this is nothing like
dreams or hallucinations or any other
type of pathologically altered
Consciousness I realized very very
quickly and as I was to learn uh even
more and more with got more and more
experiences shared with me near-death
experiences are in a word real okay so
those are the most common
characteristics of of the near-death
experiences and what's what what would
be like the your strongest evidence that
this actually happens because anybody
can kind of go on a website you know any
Nays be like anybody can go on a website
and fill it out right sure there's been
a ton of people that have done it but
like what's the most common evidence
that that you believe that this has
happened that you believe oh absolutely
you you know Theo we talked earlier
about that out of- Body Experience where
Consciousness goes above the body above
the unconscious or K's physical body
below what I and other researchers have
investigated is how accurate are those
observations in that OU of body State
and amazingly in my study over 98% of
what people are seeing and hearing with
their physical body unconscious down
below is accurate down to the finest
detail so you started to kind of
quantify or collect the experiences
people were having at that point
absolutely I've been researching and
Gathering near-death experiences for
over 25 years okay I was so fascinated
when I first heard about near-death
experiences that I really wanted to
study them but with the best methodology
possible okay and that being people that
actually had near-death experiences
sharing their firstperson experience
right so over 25 years ago I established
the near-death experience research found
Foundation a research website which
encouraged people to share a narrative
of their experience but also had a
scientifically designed huge number of
questions actually as a survey so that
not only were we getting large numbers
of near-death experiences but we were
learning about them from all those
survey questions at a depth that heret
for had been impossible okay so you
create a website where people would go
that had had near-death experiences and
they would start to just list out the
information right like what were kind of
some of the questions that would be that
you would ask to somebody sure well
first of course we have them give The
Narrative of their experience we don't
want any leading questions prior to that
time right off the bat I realized there
was overwhelming consistency even in the
first few dozen near-death experiences I
saw yeah what were some of the things
that made you that led you to believe
that they were real oh absolutely the
overwhelming consistency now while no
two near-death experiences are the same
if you study a lot of them and Theo I've
studied over 4,000 oh wow so with that
huge data set there it's kept me busy
it's my second full-time job wow St
Peter over here Milling around it yeah
it's tough to be a full-time doctor
which I'm trying to do while while doing
that as my other full-time job but I
mean just imagine that here you are
unconscious or clinically dead and yet
about a fifth of people have a Life
review or they may see part or even all
of their prior life here they are
unconscious just first often minutes
certainly you know less than 30 minutes
almost always and yet at that time
they're re reliving viewing all that
went on in their prior life an amazing
demonstration of just how rapid
Consciousness can be during a near-death
experience but what's how do you know
something is not just a dream how do you
or I'm trying to think of another word
for a dream but I don't know another
word for it yeah well that's a good one
I mean in all of our Lives we typically
have dreams that's very common
near-death experiences are nothing like
dreams Theo at the risk of embarrassment
I'm going to share you how with you how
I found out about that at the very dawn
of putting a survey up on the website I
asked the question was your experience
dreamlike in any way and oh I was
embarrassed at the responses no way no
chance absolutely not uh emphatic over
and over again for people having
near-death experiences emphasizing this
had nothing to do with dream so I I
quickly let go of that line of
questioning so again you know when you
hear about a near-death experience it
seems so unearthly people normally would
think gosh isn't that like a dream that
I'm familiar with yeah nothing
absolutely nothing like a dream it's far
more lucid and conscious were there
other choices that came up yeah I'll
tell you the most poignant choice that
we encountered in near death experiences
and that is a choice to stay in that
unearthly beautiful realm uh and
environment they're in off of their
Spirits or the choice to return to their
Earthly life and struggle to overcome
that life-threatening event that they
caused the near-death experience what
what is it and this is where it gets
really interesting Theo at that moment
of decision even though people having
the near-death experience everything
that they knew up to that time friends
family loved ones Decades of their life
often is their Earthly life and yet what
they're experiencing in this unearthly
realm overwhelm ing sense of peace and
love those are about the two most common
words used and they often describe that
they feel this unearthly beautiful realm
is their real home their true home but
the great majority of people that are in
that unearthly Heavenly realm that make
a decision or asked to make a decision
want to stay there they want to leave
their Earthly life and not come back and
believe me they uh that is a difficult
decision they will often argue with the
beings there you go to D for the first
time You' been in D oh yeah so that's
that's really
interesting that's just how compelling
and beautiful and what the sense is like
in this unearthly beautiful realm that
they're in of near-death experience is
it mostly W is it more women that fill
them out than than men CU women I think
lowkey want to die all the time I feel
like
well because they love Date Line you
know what I'm saying they're always like
oh you know they're always leaving a
window open you like that's a great
question it's probably pretty close to
5050 but I'll tell you why I think Theo
guys like us are just a little more
inclin than women to drive the car fast
to go do risky things you know swim in
places we shouldn't swim we've all been
I mean it's a guy thing so we may be a
little more predisposed to have fun in
some risky way women I think are a
little less inclined to do that so I
think that may help explain why it's
about 5050 have you ever had a
near-death experience no I haven't thank
goodness so now have you is there part
of you that
because at some point you gotta you know
put your muffins where the oven is you
know what I'm saying bro like that and
like you know what I'm saying at some
point okay there people were gonna you
know what I'm saying if you want to
write the third book you got to have to
go over there but let me tell you how it
works in the real world here Theo people
that have had a near-death experience in
general typically are not near-death
experience researchers and I think the
reason for that is they know about
near-death experience it is gripping
real they understand it they understand
its implications in their life and so as
a result of that they're not asking
questions like me and so many other
people that do research in this area
that want to know is it real what
happens so again the near-death
experience cures any near-death
experience disbelief that's for sure
does part of you ever wish like you know
and it's not nobody wants to cuz near
death experience you got a death is in
the middle of it that's the tricky part
of the rest of it you can
but death is the part you got to risk
you know but is any part of you ever
like you
know where like oh if you say you ever
been skiing and then you fall you're
like oh this could be it let's see what
happens here yeah I'll tell you I have
so many irons in the fire in my life
I've got a full-time Medical Practice uh
I love doing research and sharing about
near-death experience I've got so much
going on I'm very careful not to get
into a life-threatening event I mean one
you know I me I get where you're coming
from sure at one level it be I think an
adjunct to my research to say this is
what I experienced and here's what
happened but don't you think that might
Le to you get a little confirmation bias
and then I'd start to see other
near-death experiences through the
filter of my own experience dude I can't
believe earlier I was like we have a
don't you think there's a lot of
confirmation bias and then I just try to
talk you into confirmation bias oh
well